ايه القوه اللي عندك دي من وين جايب الصبر
والثبات اللي انت فيه ده ازاي تشيع جنازه
ولدك في النهار وتطلع تغطيها اخباريه
بالليل انت ايه يا عم وائل قول لي يا راجل
انت مين انت من نفس الطينه اللي احنا منها
ولا انت جبل لابسك انسان يا راجل انت عجزت
كل الصحفي من بعدك خليت الكاميرا اقوى من
الصاروخ النووي وصوت الميكروفون اشد من
صوت المدافع للدرجه دي جيش كامل بمخابرات
وطيرانه وصواريخه بيعمل كل ده علشان يهدك
ومش عارف للدرجه دي انت تاعبهم وحارق
اعصابهم ده انت عمرك ما مسكت بندقيه يا
ابو حمزه ولا حتى مسدس صوت ولا هو صوت
الحقيقه اللي قالق منامهم ومخليه خايفين
منك ثلاث محاولات تهد جبال الدنيا يا خال
وائل وانت لسه واقف زي السبع في قلب
الميدان اول مره قصفوا اسرتك كلها وقلت
معلش وفي نفس اليوم طلعت تغطيه اخباريه
ولكنك فقدت اعز الناس ليك يا اخي وقلت
الحمد لله سابولي حمزه وبعدها
كسفوكي وكان معاك زميلك المصور سامر ابو
دقه ومع ذلك طلعت باصابته تودع زميلك سامر
ابو دقه الله يرحمه وامبارح يا خال قتلوا
حمزه وانت يا ابو حمزه واقف تودعه كانك كل
شعب غزه وكانك انت نفسك غزه وغزه هي انت
يا دحدوح انت مين قول لي ايه الفص البشري
اللي افراده شبهك انت مستحيل تكون زينا
انت اكيد جاي من زمن الصحابه علشان تعلمنا
الصبر والثبات انت بتعمل ايه في زمنا احنا
في زمن خنوع وخضوع انت جاي هنا تعمل ايه
جاي تحرجنا يا خال ولا ايه بالظبط احنا
الصحافه عندنا تكييف والجل فيها تحريف
والمعارك الصحفيه عندنا عباره عن انفصال
الفنان عن الفنانه انت ازاي الصحافه عندك
هي محاربه جيش بيقود حرب باباده على شعب
اعزل وانت واقف في وشه وحدك وسلاحك هي
ميكروفونك وكاميرته وبعد ده كله ثابت وصلب
وواقف في وش المصايب وبتقول معلش يا جبل
ما يهزك ريح خالص العزاء مقدمه من سهاج
قلب الصعيد عن لسان كل راجل صعيدي حر
بيقول لك عظم الله اجرك يا ابو حمزه ولو
علينا كنا قلنا لك من يوم 7 اكتوبر خلي
عنك يا ابو عمو ارضك هي ارضي وعرضك هو
عرضي حسبي الله ونعم
الوكيل